this is the fourth year we're playing
here in Bucharest Romania what do you
enjoy about being back here in Bucharest
to Kickstart the grandchester
I I like to say a lot I've been to
Bucharest not only the four times that
the grand just tour has been here but
also twice in 2012 and 2013 so six times
total and
um yeah it's always great to be here I
like the country I like the city it's
it's a really vibrant City I mean big
cities have their own kind of special
energy and I guess I'm not like always
so used to it I grew up in New York
which has like a very similar energy but
in St Louis it's a bit more of like a
medium-sized City so it's a lot more
calm when you go out you don't always
see like a million people but that has
its own charm as well yeah bucharesta
obviously I I switched the federations
to Romania so this is uh my second
tournament here in Bucharest but my
first one is playing on the Romania flag
yeah Booker is is a very special place
um there are not many tournaments that
are happening here but now it's really
amazing and really well organized
everything I love the city the people
are great here very helping people and
everywhere we go we have a good time so
I'm very happy yeah and I know that
Bucharest is considered to be a Paris or
the East right okay because I play at
home
it's more supporting Romania than other
countries
looks a bit more important for me I
really like the city which process
surprisingly surprisingly nice I like
like the architecture yes like some
weather is quite quite mild and warm uh
so yeah I guess uh we'll take only good
emotions from here I'm really happy to
be back to Bucharest I was here already
two times and every time I come back you
know the organizers they only
improving and
um
building on what they've done and
Bucharest
for these two weeks of the capital of
the the Chess World and in general with
so many events happening in Romania and
so much just life around here Bucharest
is turning into a you know a big big
Center of jazz activity and that's
wonderful to see yeah it's my short time
in Bucharest and I I enjoy it it's very
comfortable to be here there are many
people speaking French as well so it's
it does feel very comfortable other than
that obviously like during the
tournament I prioritize the tournament
and not sightseeing and such but uh no
it's still very good to get some fresh
air to to go outside we're in very
central location so that's also nice
always lovely it's my fourth year here I
it's gonna become a tradition I really
enjoyed coming here since 2019 and the
people are really friendly I meet again
the people I usually meet I have some
friends here so it's it's a lovely
wonderful hopefully my play would
be up to par with it and that's the
reason why I came
[Music]